ايها
المسلمون اتواصل
معكم ما
بداته في الجمعه
الماضيه وما ذكرته لكم في خطبه
العيد اعاد الله
عليكم هذا العيد المبارك عيد
الاضحى
بالخير واليمن والبركات
والسلامه والايمان
والاطمئنان وقد وصلت
معكم ان سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام لبث
كثيرا لم
يزر
هاجر وابنه
اسماعيل بعد ان تركهما
في واد غير ذي
زرع عند بيت الله
المحرم واستمر على ذلك
طويلا ثم جاء بعد
ذلك ثم قال لابنه لابنه اسماعيل عليه
السلام يا
اسماعيل ان الله امرني
بامر فقال اسماعيل عليه
السلام يا
ابتي اصنع ما امرك الله
به فقال
ابراهيم
وتعينني انظر الى بر الولد
بابيه بهذا
الاب الذي تركه سنوات طويله
وتعينني قال
واعينك فقال ابراهيم عليه
السلام
امرني الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان ابني هاهنا
بيتا
واشار الى مكان
بيت الذي هو الكعبه
المشرفه فعند ذاك
رفع القواعد من
البيت واذ يرفع ابراهيم القواعد من البيت
واسماعيل ما معنى هذا
الكلام؟ معنى هذا
الكلام ان البيت اصلا كان
موجودا كما ذكرته لكم في الخطب
السابقه
ولكن بعد الطوفان
رفع الله سبحانه وتعالى البيت الى السماء
الرابعه وفي روايه الى السماء
السابعه وبقيت
القواعد فجاء
ابراهيم عليه السلام مع ابنه
اسماعيل
ورفع بناء هذا
البيت فجعل اسماعيل ياتي
بالحجاره وابراهيم
يبني حتى اذا ارتفع
البناء جاء بهذا
الحجر فوضعه له اي الحجر الاسود
فقام
عليه ثم جاء بحجر
اخر فكان يقف على هذه
الاحجار ويرفع ببناء
الكعبه وهو ما يسمى بمقام ابراهيم عليه
السلام ومن معجزاته عليه الصلاه والسلام
ان اثر ر قدمه قائمه الى ان تقوم
الساعه فقام عليه وهو يبني واسماعيل
يناوله الحجاره وهما
يقولان ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم فجعلا
بنياني حتى يدور حول
البيت
ويقول ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم بعد
ذلك جاء امر
اخر وابتلاء
اخر لسيدنا
ابراهيم وابنه اسماعيل عليه
السلام قال
تعالى فلما بلغ معه السعي قال يا بني اني
ارى في المنام اني
اذبحك فانظر ماذا
ترى قال مجاهد رحمه
الله اي شب
وارتحل واطاق ما يفعله ابوه من السعي
والعمل فلما كان هذا راى ابراهيم عليه
السلام في المنام انه يؤمر بذبح ولده
هذا وفي الحديث عن ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما انه
قال عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم رؤيا الانبياء
وحي
وهذا اختبار من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
لخليله في ان يذبح هذا الولد
العزيز الذي جاءه على
كبر وقد طعن ابراهيم في
السن بعدما امر بان
يسكنه هو
وامه في بلاد
قفر
وواد ليس به
حسيس ولا انيس ولا زرع ولا
ضرع فامتثل
ابراهيم لامر الله تعالى في
ذلك لانه عليه الصلاه
والسلام
تركهما هناك ثقه بالله سبحانه وتعالى
وتوكلا عليه عز
وجل فجعل الله سبحانه
وتعالى لهما فرجا
ومخرجا
ورزقهما من حيث لا
يحتسبان لان
التقوى
كانت عامره في
قلوبهم والله تعالى يقول ومن يتق
الله يجعل له
مخرجا ويرزقه من حيث لا
يحتسب
ثم عرض ابراهيم عليه
السلام هذا
الامر على ولده ليكون اطيب
لقلبه واهون عليه من ان ياخذه
قسرا ويذبحه قهرا
قال يا بني اني ارى في المنام ان اذبحك
فانظر ماذا
ترى فبادر الغلام
الحليم
طاعه
لوالده خليل الرحمن عليه الصلاه والسلام
فقال يا ابتي افعل ما
تؤمر ستجدني ان شاء الله من الصابرين
وهذا اخي المسلم اختي
المسلمه هذا الجواب في غايه السداد
والطاعه
للوالد ولرب
العباد لان
اسماعيل
عرف حق
اليقين ان طاعه الوالدين
من طاعه الرب سبحانه
وتعالى ورضا
الوالدين من رضا من رضا الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وكذلك سخط الله من سخط
الوالدين
فاحذروا حقوق
وليكن سيد سيدنا
اسماعيل
نموذجا راقيا
لكم تحتذون
به قال تعالى فلما
اسلم اي انقاد ما امرهم الله به فلما
اسلم وتله
للجبين نودي من الله عز وجل
ان يا
ابراهيم قد صدقت
الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين اي قد حصل
المقصود من اختبارك
وطاعتك ومبادرتك الى امر
ربك وكما مالك
مبذول
للضيفان ولهذا قال تعالى ان هذا لهو
البلاء المبين
اي الاختبار
الظاهر البين الواضح فكانت
المكافاه عظيمه من الله سبحانه
وتعالى قال تعالى وفديناه بذبح عظيم اي
وجعلنا
فداءه لذبح ولده ما
يسره له من العوض عنه عن ابن عباس رضي
الله عنهما
قال كبش قد راى في الجنه 40
خليفا وعند جلب
الفداء من قبل جبريل عليه السلام كبر وهو
في السماء وقال الله اكبر الله
اكبر
فاجابه سيدنا
ابراهيم عليه
السلام الاجابه
ه جبريل عليه السلام الله اكبر الله
اكبر وعندما وصل
بالفداء قال
اسماعيل ولله
الحمد
فهذا التكبير الذي نعمله في في الاعياد
وخاصه في عيد الاضحى المبارك هو ما حصل
بين جبريل عليه
السلام وسيدنا ابراهيم
وسيدنا اسماعيل عليهما السلام الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر ولله الحمد ادعوا الله وانتم
موقنون بالاجابه